rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une petite balade au-dessus de Saint-Leu
le sentier pavé qui surplombe la ravine
fontaine jusqu'à la route des Tamarins
pouvoir rendez-vous sur la côte ouest à
l'entrée nord de Saint-Leu le parking de
la ravine fontaine plus connu sous le
nom de la ravine Saint-Leu ou en lieu
des spectacles et notre point de départ
notre accompagnatrice Corinne mezensif
de 21 rando-sud nous a donné rendez-vous
en fin de journée pour profiter des
lumières du soleil couchant
le départ du sentier n'est pas indiqué
mais très facile à trouver une fois de
l'autre côté du grillage il faut longer
le parking pendant quelques mètres avant
de plonger vers la ravine fontaine
de l'autre côté on retrouve le fameux
sentier pavé dont certaines parties
datent du 18e siècle
curiosité du site la présence de deux
espèces de fougères endémiques
particulièrement cette fougère latanée
dont les petites feuilles quand elles ne
sont pas sèches rappelle la forme des
arbres du même nom
un peu plus haut à Sainte intersection
un crochet sur la gauche permet de
surplomber la ravine et d'atteindre un
superbe point de vue sur la ville et sur
la mer on a fait un petit crochet
très beau point de vue
la vague la fameuse vague de Saint-Leu
on voit aussi tout au fond là-bas la
Pointe au Sel et puis aussi
historiquement il s'est passé quelque
chose ici ça s'appelle la batterie des
sans-culottes parce que pendant les
guerres napoléoniennes et bien les
Anglais
voulaient un petit peu envahir Lille
donc ils sont venus ici on s'est protégé
donc
par cette batterie et à la Grande
Chaloupe il y avait pas de batterie
finalement et c'est là que les Anglais
ont débarqué ont pris le fameux chemin
des Anglais qui en fait n'a pas été
construit comme certains le pense par
les Anglais ils ont juste il a juste été
emprunté par les Anglais
ce sentier comme souvent dans l'Ouest
servait autrefois à faire le lien entre
les hauts et les bas encore aujourd'hui
les locaux aiment l'emprunter comme en
témoignent la présence de cette petite
chapelle de Saint-Exupéry
et si très vite les pavés disparaissent
on peut encore faire des découvertes
sous nos pieds comme cette roche pintade
dont le moustache comme le nom l'indique
rappelle le plus mal d'une pintade en
fait c'est donc des cristaux blancs de
felspat dans une matrice sombre et en
fait ça quand même ça vient du Piton des
Neiges ici on est quand même plutôt sur
le massif du Piton des Neiges et ça date
plutôt des éruptions des de la des
dernières phases irruptives du Piton des
Neiges donc les cristaux se forment il
faut que ce le cristal enfin que la
roche reste longtemps dans les chambres
magmatiques et donc il faut un
refroidissement lent et le cristal la
peut se former
après les pavés le sentier en terre au
milieu des arbres fruitiers reste très
praticable
essaie de façon soudaine que l'arrivée
sur une piste face à la roue des
Tamarins change radicalement l'ambiance
en faisant un autre petit crochet on
atteint très vite ce point de vue
aménagé sur le pont de la ravine
fontaine un des quatre ouvrages d'art de
la roue des Tamarins quand on arrive ici
ça c'est étonnant parce qu'on était dans
la nature et là tout d'un coup on arrive
sur cet ouvrage d'Arc et qu'un ouvrage
d'art impressionnant qu'on a vu se
construire en plus c'était vraiment
étonnant la construction parce qu'en
fait c'est un point encore bellement et
les deux côtés comme ça ce sont
construits de chaque côté et au milieu
il y avait le vide et on a mis la
dernière partie moi je sais que ça m'a
vraiment impressionné c'est un grand
pont il fait 110 mètres de profondeur
200 m de large et puis surtout on passe
tous les jours dessus sans forcément
voir ce côté justement qui est pas loin
d'un petit sentier finalement et quand
on passe après sur la route des Tamarins
on dit tiens il y a un petit sentier pas
loin
le sentier continue de l'autre côté de
la roue des Tamarins si l'on décide
d'emprunter le tunnel dans une ambiance
différente et sans pavés mais pour nous
la randonnée Sacha vici avec la tombée
de la nuit
alors je vous ai amené sur ce sentier
d'abord pour sa proximité par rapport à
Saint-Leu c'est quand on habite
Saint-Leu vite on peut faire une petite
balade au soir ou le matin voilà pour
faire un petit footing c'est très
agréable vite on s'éloigne du bruit la
ville et ça j'aime bien cette sensation
moi je préfère plutôt le soir au coucher
de soleil parce que on a souvent un beau
rayon vert et ça j'affectionne beaucoup
c'est un sentier qui est très facile on
peut le faire en famille on peut le
faire justement au rythme footing plutôt
on peut le faire le soir le matin mais
vraiment à éviter en pleine journée
parce qu'elle fait une chaleur terrible
il y a pas beaucoup d'eau même s'il y a
quelques bois noir qui font un petit peu
dents il y a vraiment pas beaucoup
d'ombre et donc c'est vrai que on peut
le faire avec des enfants sans problème
il y a que 200 modes de dénivelé et
voilà ça peut se faire en une heure et
demie tranquillement ce que j'aime moins
sur ce sentier c'est effectivement
la chaleur et peut-être aussi le
la femme malheureusement même si on peut
passer sous la route des Tamarins
la fin est moins intéressante donc je
m'arrête ici mais on peut relier
jusqu'au je sais des 13 et redescendre
par le sentier par exemple de la Salette